السلام عليكم
انا يوسف اسامه
هو انا متخصص في الاثار الاسلاميه
والفريقس كلمني من حوالي 10 ايام انا ما
كنتش عارف ان انا هتكلم على ايه لغايه
امبارح هي فرح قالت لي
التوب بتاعه ربع ساعه فاحنا اخترنا ان انا
اتكلم معكم في بسرعه كده عن الجوامع اللي
على العمله
الموضوع ده ان احنا عندنا العملات الورقيه
هي تسع ورقات اللي هي ربع جنيه نص جنيه
انا عايز الصوره بس من فضلكم
هنا شايفين في تسعه طبعا الربع جنيه ونص
جنيه لما بيتطبع دلوقتي عندنا الجنيه اللي
هي العمله الرسميه
الخمسه جنيه العشره جنيه ال 20 جنيه ال50
ال 100 ال 200
العملات دي كلها
هي في القاهره يعني الدوله قررت ان هي تحط
على الوش زي ما احنا شايفين اثر اسلام
وعلى الظهر اثر مصدر قديم احنا مش هناخذ
المصدر القديم مش هناخد الضهر علشان الوقت
فخلينا على الوش من اول الربع جنيه اه ده
جامع هو جامع السيده عائشه حد يعرفه هو في
القاهره
الجمع ده الجامع الوحيد اللي على العمله
ومش ازلي يعني ده مبني جديد
وتقريبا يعني مجلس السبعينات الايام
الرئيس السادات هو كان مكانه جامع قديم في
المكان ده انا واحد اسمه عبد الرحمن كانت
هدى في القرن ال 18 وبعدين اتشال واتبنى
مكانه في الجامع ده فهو الجامع الوحيد
اللي من التسع جوامع اللي موجودين على
العمله وجامع مش اثري اللي بعدهم
وبالمناسبه برضو السيده عائشه دي مش هي
السيده عائشه اللي هي زوجه الرسول محمد هي
اسمها عائشه بنت جعفر الصادق ابن محمد
الباقر ابن زين العابدين ابن الحسين بن
علي ده الجامع الازهر
نبص هنا نلاقي على الازهر في ثلاث مقاس
يعني الصوره دي هو ده مصور اسمه بيشوي
فايز هو اللي خد يعني دي الصور لهم هو
اللي قرر يعمل
الصور بالشكل ده يعني فجب ماذنه وهو يعني
نص جنيه بحيث ان هو اخذ مئزنه الماذنه دي
بتاعه السلطان الغوري
لو بصينا على الجمع الازهر من الجامع
الازهر خمس مازق في ثلاثه منهم على اللقطه
بتاعه الخمسين قرش هو خد الماذنه اللي هي
بتاعه
المحزنه النبرصين وفي بعدها مئزنه بتاعه
السلطان قايتباي وبعدين مئزنه بتاعه من
عبد الواحد الصوره اللي بعدها
دي بقى الجنيه او العمله الرسميه اللي هو
يعني ما عدناش نشوفه كتير ورقه يعني حتى
لو في القاهره لما باجي هنا
احيانا باديه الناس هنا مش عارف ازاي لان
احنا بقينا بنستخدم اكتر
الجنيه هو عليه جمع السلطان
هتسمع
اكيد هو صاحب القلعه اللي في اسكندريه
سلطان كانت فايته هو صاحب اطول فتره حكم
في تاريخ دوله المماليك يعني ده راجل حكم
29 سنه
حكم مصر والشام
برضو من
الخمسه الاوائل في تاريخ مصر الاسلاميه من
حيث مده
الحكم يعني عندنا اكثر حاكم في تاريخ مصر
حد يعرف
فترته قد ايه
كمعلومه عامه يعني
الخليفه المستنصر الفاطمه ده خمس الخلفاء
الفاطميين ده حكم 60 سنه حكم وهو عنده سبع
سنين وهو عنده 67 سنه فحكم 60 سنه ده صاحب
اطول فتره في تاريخ مصر الاسلاميه بعد
الخليفه المستنصر ده ثاني واحد هو محمد
علي باشا محمد علي باشا حكم 43 سنه وبعد
محمد علي باشا الناصر محمد بن القروان ده
في العصر المملوكي حكم 42 سنه وبعدين رقم
اربعه حسني مبارك حكم 30 سنه وبعدين رقم
خمسه هو السلطان حكم 29 سنه احنا قررنا
والدوله قررت ان هي تحط جمع السلطان على
الجنيه وبالمناسبه الجامع هنلاقي فيه
مئذنه وفيه قبه جراحيه القبه اللي على
الشمال دي دي بنسمعه ضريحيه يعني ده هو
عمل الجامع ده كمدرسه لتدريس المدارس
السنيه وفي نفس الوقت يبقى فيها
القبه دي
المؤرخين الاماره
اصطلحوا ان هم يشبهوا سلطان
يعني الناس اللي بتدرس عماره يقولوا
هو اكثر سلطان بناء في تاريخ مصر
الاسلاميه اكتر حدنا منشات ساب لنا اكثر
من حوالي 70 منشاه
الصوره اللي بعدها نشوف كده اهو ده بقى
الجنيه يعني دي بالصدفه بالمناسبه يعني
الصدفه جمعت بين رمسيس الثاني
وبين السلطان على الجنيه هي ما كانتش
مقصوده احنا قلنا ان هم بيشبهوا
ان هو اكتر سلطان بناء اكثر فرعون او ملك
في تاريخ مصر القديمه بقى بناء هو كان
رمسيس الثاني واعظم بناء سابه يعتبر معبد
ابو سمبل فلذلك هنلاقيه على الجنيه مع
السلطان ودي تاني
غير الصوره اللي بعدها
اهو
في مصر الاسلاميه
على حل هو خلصوا في سنه احمد بنطلون
افتتحوا للصلاه في 265 هجري
879 جنيه
فبنتكلم ان عمره اكتر من 1150 سنه بس انا
لما اقول معلومه زي دي حد يقول لي طب ازاي
وجاء عمرو بن العاص هو المفروض اول جامع
في مصر في افريقيا يعني عمرو بن العاص بنى
الجامع بتاعه في سنه 20 هجري 640 ميلادي
في 265 هجري
879 ميلادي ازاي لان الجامع عمرو بن العاص
القديم ولذلك عمرو بن العاص مثلا مش مرسوم
على العمله الجامع ولا عندنا اصلا ولا
حاجه هو مهم من الناحيه التاريخيه ليه
لانه اقدم جامعه في مصر وفي افريقيا صحيح
لكن مش بتبقي اي حاجه من عصر عمرو بن
العاص يعني مش متبقي منه غير قطعه الارض
اللي تبان عليها
طول عمرو بن العاص كان 25 في 15 متر ده
الجامع القديم النهارده الجامع بتاع عمرو
بن العاص 112 متر ونصف يعني
الضعف المساحه انما جامع احمد
يجري 879 ميلادي هو في حالته دي صحيح
اتغير فيه حاجات مع الزمن في حاجات اتهدد
اتعمل له ترميمات فوق اصلاحات اعملوا
تجديدات لكن هو محافظ على من الوقت ده
فجمع احمد البترول موجود معنا على خمسه
جنيه وهو جايب بقى
الماذون يعني لو احنا بصينا في الصوره دي
هنلاقي في مئزنتين
الماذنه اللي هي بتاعه احمد ودي هي
الماذنه الوحيده اللي في مصر بالشكل ده من
زمان الماذنه الملويه ملويه ودي
ان السلم بتاع الماذنه بيدور حول بدنها
السلم من الخارج كل الماذن عندنا في مصر
الاسلاميه وحتى في مصر الحديثه
ده اللي هي على الخمسه جنيه اللي هي لازق
في الخمسه جنيه على
[موسيقى]
طول خارجي في بنلاقي فيه مئذنه تانيه ورا
كده دي مئزنه امير
مملوك
العصر للسلطان حسن فتره برده اللي هو يعني
بالتحديد في سنه 757 هجري 1356 ميلادي
اللي يهمنا في في مئزنه صرغاتش
والقبه بقى احمد كلنا عارفين العلامه ابن
خلدون اكيد سمعته عنه لما جه مصر كان
بيدرس في المدرسه اللي هي وراء جامع احمد
الصوره اللي بعدها
عندنا هنا العشره جنيه
العشره جنيه الجديده اتحط عليها جمع جديد
اللي هو جمع الفتاح العليم لكن احنا يهمنا
في العشره
القديمه اللي هو جامع الرفاعي
وزي ما احنا قلنا ان جامع السيده عائشه هو
الجامع الوحيد الغير اسد
فجمع الرفاعي بقى هو
اجدد جامع اثري بس هو اسد اللي هو معدل
100 سنه يعني هو افتضح للصلاه سنه 1912
فهو طالما عدى 100 سنه المفروض ان هو كده
بيتسجل اثر يعني المفروض ان هو يبقى اثر
لو هو قلنا 1912 يعني في 2012 بس هو تسجل
اثر في الثمانينات سنه 86 سجل اصلا قبل ما
يتم
ال 100 لايك العربيه يعني له قصه كده
طويله ان خشياره هانم اللي هي والده
الخديوي اسماعيل كانت بتعتقد في شيخ اسمه
علاء ابو شباك وكانت عايزه تدفن جنبه كان
شباك له
في
فقررت ان هي تشتري الارض وتهد المدخل ده
وتعمل الجامع الكبير عشان تدفن جنب الشيخ
علي ابو الشباك ده هو ده جامع الرفاعي
قدام على طول جامع السلطان حسن
اللي بعده
جمع محمد علي على العشرين جنيه
ناس كتير لما بتشوف الصوره دي بتقول
القلعه صح
يعني حتى في ناس بالغلط يقولوا قلعت محمد
علي
هو جامع محمد علي داخل قلقت صلاح الدين
بس محمد علي لما بنى الجامع بتاعه ده هو
منعنا التراث العثماني مع
بدا نفسي سنه 1830 وخلصه في سنه 18
18 سنه
ده هو مبنى على الطراز العثماني يعني
الطراز العثماني بيبني الجامع ازاي زي ما
احنا شايفين كده ان في البدايه اصلا
فمحمد علي في
اعلى ما يحط الجامع بتاعه فالناس لما تبص
تشوف القاهره اول يعني
اعلى وتشوفوه هي قلعت صلاح الدين كاع
لى معهد هو محمد علي فلذلك بالغلط بنقول
ايه بنقول جامع محمد علي طراز العثماني
اللي هو القبه المركزيه شوفوا حتى ده اللي
راح اسطنبول او شاف اسطنبول في جمع
السلطان احمد اكيد سمعته عنه هو محمد علي
هو تقليد لجمع السلطان احمد اللي هي
الماذنه المدببه اللي هي واخده شكل القلم
الرصاص
صغيره في الاربع اركان ليه لان ما ينفعش
يعمل الجامع السقف بتاعه مسطح لان لو عمل
الجامع زي زي الجوامع المصريه زي الجامع
الازهر كده عندنا ان الجامع يبقى
مفتوح هناك الجو برد في اسطنبول فالثلج
هينزل في المطر فالمصلين هيبرد فلازم ان
هو يغطي بصفائح
يغطي يعني ما يتجمعش على السطح وياثر على
السطح
اه ده جمع من مش مشهور قوي بس هو غريب
شويه في حاجه
ده الاصحاب
لو احنا بصينا اللي معاه خمسين جنيه
دلوقتي ويطلعها يبص عليها يلاقي مكتوب بخط
صغير كده مسجد ابو حريبه او جامعه ابو
حريبه
مع انه ده امير مملوك طب مين ابو حريبه ده
الاسحاقي ده كلكم رحتوا زرتوا قلعه
قايتباي اللي في اسكندريه اعتقد ما فيش حد
فينا مظهرش اسكندريه وما فيش حد ما راحش
اسكندريه لازم تروح قلع الطيبات ده كان
امير عند السلطان وكان نائب اسكندريه في
سنه بعد سنه 1480 في الوقت ده وهو
القاهره مش في اسكندريه وبعدين هو بعد كده
السلطان كانت باينه
الشام لما مات الدفن في الشام الدفن
بره فالقبه بتاعه الج
امد دي المفروض الراجل ده كان يدفن فيها
بعد ما يموت لكن احنا قلنا ان هو خلاص
بقى فضلت فاضيه من سنه 1480 لغايه سنه
1852 شيخ صوفي شيخ طريقه الشيخ احمد ابو
حريبه دخل في القبه دي بعد حوالي 400 سنه
من بناء الجامع اتعرف الجامع بعد كده بجمع
ايه جامع ابو هريبه واتكتبوا بدا اسمه
الشهره والاسم الاشهر حتى كاتبين على
العمله كده وانقام بالخطا جامعه بحريه
الصوره اللي بعدها
ده جمع ال 100 جنيه اللي هو جمع السلطان
حسن
يعتبر هرم العماره الاسلاميه وبالمناسبه
حتى تقدروا تعملوا سيرش على فيسبوك او على
جوجل في زياره اوباما لما جزار مصر هو جاد
زار السلطان حسن في سنه 2008 وبعدين راح
قال الخطاب بتاعه الشهير اللي كان في
جامعه القاهره
المؤرخين بيشبهوا الجامعه ان كان لمصر
الفرعونيه ان تفخر باهرامات فان لمصر
الاسلاميه انت فيها عجبا في مدرسه السلطان
حسن ودي كانت متخصصه للت المدارس والنار
اربعه الصوره اللي انتم شايفينها على
الميه جنيه دي اللي هي على يمين رقم الميه
دي الشبابيك
الغرف بتاعه المدرسه الحنفيه لانها كانت
متخصصه الاربع مزارع في شبابيك قصادها
الناحيه الثانيه كانت للمدرسه الشافعيه
والمدرسه الملكيه والمدرسه الحنفيه الصوره
اسمه جامع قليبي الرماح
او قالبي امير اخوه ده برضه الجامع ده
في ده منين والعشرين جنيه
ميدان القلعه على العشره قلنا جامع
الرفاعي والعشرين جنيه جامع محمد علي جامع
ال 100 جنيه السلطان حسن برده في ميدان
القلعه هو قدام الرفاعي على طول الجامع ده
جنبهم جمع قلي بره شايفين الصوره بصوا كده
على الشمال خالص
في دي
شوف
300 متر وجمع السيده عائشه ب 300 متر
فاحنا بنتكلم ان المربع في القاهره حوالي
500 متر
ب 500 في ست عملات من التسعه الجمع ده بقى
متميز بان الماذنه بتاعته براسيه لما جينا
اتكلمنا عن الماذنه بتاعه
بالشكل ده ماذنه ده كان في نهايه العصر
المملوك الجامع ده بعد سنه 1500 رماح لانه
هو كان بيلعب بالرمح دي هنختم بيها
عارفين ان اهم احتفال في مصر الاسلاميه هو
الاحتفال بدوران المحمل وخروج قصه الكعبه
الكسوه اللي انتم بتشوفوها على الكعبه دي
زمان كانت بتطلع من مصر وكان بيبقى في
مماليك اسم
هم المماليك الرماحه دول كانوا بيلبسوا
احمر وبيلعبوا بالرمح فوق ظهور الخيل فوق
ظهر الخيل ده كان واحد منهم من المماليك
الرماحه دول فالشهر بكده وكان بارع في
اللعبه دي فتعرض بقالبي الرماح واشكركم
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[تصفيق]